>>> TOP OF THE HOUR.
I'M ALLISON.
>> I'M VICTOR.
MORE THAN 1 MILLION PUERTO
RICANS ARE WITHOUT POWER.
THE WATER WASHED AWAY THIS
BRIDGE AS IT MADE LANDFALL.
FIONA IS A TROPICAL STORM AND
BATTERING THE ISLAND WITH HEAVY
WINDS AND CATASTROPHIC FLASH
FLOODS.
>> HUNDREDS OF FEMA WORKERS ARE
ON THE GROUND.
THE PRESIDENT IS ASSURING PUERTO
RICO WE STAND WITH YOU AND WILL
GET THROUGH THIS TOGETHER.
CNN'S LAILA SANTIAGO IS LIVE IN
SAN JUAN WHERE THE RISING WATER
IS THE MAJOR CONCERN.
LAILA, WHAT ARE YOU SEEING?
>> Reporter: IN SAN JUAN IN THE
NORTHWESTERN PART OF THE ISLAND
IT IS DIFFERENT THAN WHAT THEY
SEEING ON THE INTERIOR AND
EASTERN PART OF THE ISLAND.
SO I KNOW VICTOR SHOWED THAT
VIDEO OF THE BRIDGE WASHED AWAY.
I TALKED TO A YOUNG MAN THERE
LAST NIGHT WHEN IT HAPPENED AND
SAID HE WAS LOOKING OUTSIDE THE
WINDOW AND HAPPENED WITHIN A
MATTER OF MINUTES.
THIS MORNING I GOT INTO SALINA
ON THE SOUTHEASTERN PART OF THE
ISLAND AND THERE IS A LOT OF
CONCERN AND FRUSTRATION AMONG
THE PEOPLE I TALKED TO.
LISTEN TO AN EXCHANGE WITH A
GENTLEMAN THERE, A RESIDENT AND
A BUSINESS OWNER.
>> MORE PEOPLE LOST THE HOUSES
THAN MARIA.
THAT WAS TOUGH WINDS BUT THIS
WITH THE RAIN DESTROYED
EVERYTHING ON HOUSES.
IT IS A SMALL TOWN THAT
BASICALLY WHO'S GOING TO TAKE
CARE OF THIS TOWN?
NOBODY.
IF WE DON'T NOBODY WILL TAKE
CARE OF IT.
>> Reporter: THAT WAS THE
SENTIMENT I HEARD FROM SEVERAL
PEOPLE ESPECIALLY GOING TO THE
SHELT JER THE MAYOR SAID THEY
HAVE MORE THAN 2500 FAMILIES
IMPACTED BY THE FLOODING RIGHT
NOW THAT DOESN'T STOP BECAUSE
THE REMNANTS OF NOW TROPICAL
STORM FIONA POUND THIS ISLAND.
SO IT'S NOT JUST THE FLOODING
AND THE MUDSLIDES WE SAW ON THE
MAIN HIGHWAY THAT WE WATCHED AS
CREWS TRIED TO GET CONTROL BUT
WATER.
60% OF THE CUSTOMERS DON'T HAVE
WATER PART OF THAT NOT AVAILABLE
BECAUSE THEY DEPEND ON POWER TO
GET THE WATER.
THE MAJORITY OF THE ISLAND IS
WITHOUT POWER RIGHT NOW.
THEY HAVE BEEN ABLE TO RESTORE A
PART BIT BUT THE POWER IS WHAT
CAUSES THE ANXIETY FROM THE
FLOODS AND THE IMAGES THAT YOU
ARE STARTING TO SEE BECAUSE THE
TIMING HERE.
TOMORROW WILL BE FIVE YEARS
SINCE HURRICANE MARIA DESTROYED
THE ISLAND AND LEFT WITHOUT
POWER FOR MONTHS.
>> WITHOUT POWER AND WITH
ANXIETY AFTER THE STORM
APPROACHED.
LEYLA, THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> IN ADDITION TO THE FEMA
WORKERS ON THE GROUND
CALIFORNIA, NEW YORK AND NEW
JERSEY ARE SENDING IN PEOPLE TO
HELP.
>> COMING THE ISLAND'S
INFRASTRUCTURE AND POWER GRID
OFFICIALS SAY THEY ARE MUCH
BETTER PREPARED THAN MARIA FIVE
YEARS AGO.
CRAIG FUGATE IS HERE.
THAT MAN SAID THIS IS WORSE THAN
MARIA.
ACROSS THE ISLAND AND THE
VARIABLES IS THIS WORSE THAN
MARIA?
>> WELL, THE FLOODING IS GOING
TO BE WORSE.
MARIA WAS PRIMARILY WINDS.
WHERE WE HAVE THE COMMUNITIES
THAT THE FLOODING IS TAKING
PLACE, BLOWING OUT THE ROADS AND
THE INFRASTRUCTURE IS IMPACTED
AGAIN.
SO WHERE THE FLOODING IS TAKING
PLACE IT IS PROBABLY AS BAD IF
NOT WORSE THAN MARIA BUT I DON'T
THINK WE'LL SEE THAT LEVEL OVER
THE ENTIRE ISLAND SIMILAR TO THE
WIND DAMAGE WE SAW FROM MARIA.
>> THAT SAID, CRAIG, WE REMEMBER
FIVE YEARS AGO HOW LONG WE HAD
TO REPORT ON THE POWER OUTAGES
BECAUSE OF MARIA.
IT WENT ON FOR MANIES.
SOME PLACES FOR 11 MONTHS WHY
NOW FIVE YEARS.
HAVE THEY SHORED UP THE POWER
GRID SINCE 1.3 MILLION CUSTOMERS
ARE WITHOUT POWER?
WHAT IS THE STATUS ON PUERTO
RICO?
>> WE ARE ABOUT TO FIND OUT.
THEY HAD DONE A LOT OF
REBUILDING.
SOME WAS DONE REALLY QUICKLY
AFTER THE STORM TO GET POWER
BACK AND THEN WOULD DO PERMANENT
WORK SO THIS IS AN EXAMPLE THAT
AS WE SAW FROM HURRICANE KATRINA
AND SEEING FROM HURRICANE
KATRINA MARIA REBUILDING TAKES
YEARS IF NOT DECADES SO HOW MUCH
HAS BEEN DONE, WHAT I'M
CONCERNED ABOUT IS WE HAD A LOT
OF NEW ENERGY SYSTEMS IN THE
SYSTEM.
AFTER MARIA THE CONDITION OF THE
ROADS SO THE REPAIR CREWS GET IN
TO REPLACE POWER LINES.
YOU SEE BRIDGES AND ROADS WASHED
OUT.
I THINK WE'LL SEE A LOT OF THOSE
SIMILAR THINGS.
WHAT WE NEED TO WAIT AND SEE IS
HOW MUCH OF THE GRID IS DIRECTLY
IMPACTED BY WINDS.
SO WIDESPREAD WITH MARIA OR
ISOLATED AND CAN MAKE THE
REPAIRS?
>> THEY CAN'T GO THROUGH THIS
EVERY COUPLE OF YEARS.
WE HAVE DISCUSSED BUILDING A
MORE RESILIENT INFRASTRUCTURE.
WE TALKED ABOUT IN THE CONTEXT
OF THE CONTINUOUS 48 BUT FOR
PUERTO RICO WHAT NEEDS TO HAPPEN
SO WHEN A CAT 1 WITH THIS AMOUNT
OF RAIN IS NOT AS DISASTROUS AS
IT IS NOW?
>> WELL, WE HAVE SEEN SOME
THINGS THAT WERE REPAIRED AFTER
MARIA GET WASHED AWAY.
IT IS IMPORTANT WHEN WE REBUILD
WE BUILD FOR THE FUTURE AND
UNDERSTAND WHAT HAPPENED IN
MARIA IS WIND.
SOME COMMUNITYS THAT ARE
FLOODING HADN'T HAD THAT MARIA
SO WE'RE STILL UNCOVERING THAT
WHERE WE HAVE PEOPLE LIVING AND
THE COMMUNITIES AND GO BACK AND
REBUILD, WE HAVE TO BUILD BACK
AGAINST ALL THE THREATS.
NOT JUST WIND BUT WATER AND IN
PUERTO RICO WE HAVE SEEN A LOT
OF DEATHS.
PEOPLE BEING RESCUED.
THE ISSUE YOU'RE RAISING IS
INSTANTY OF PUTTING IT BACK THE
WAY IT WAS ISN'T WORK JG WE HAVE
TO FOCUS ON MAKING THE
INVESTMENTS TO REBUILD BECAUSE
THE CLIM